muy buenas tardes para ti en principio
indicarte que estamos realizando este
informe del consejo nacional electoral
donde será aquí en este lugar
formalmente donde se realice el acto de
inauguración de las comisiones 7 de
febrero informarte también que ya se han
realizado dos jornadas previas de
votación de un principio los privados de
libertad pero mucho 1300 personas sin
sentencia ejecutoriada en 39 recintos
electorales quienes ya realizaron el
voto de igual forma también el programa
del voto en casa este programa consiste
en beneficiar a las personas registradas
son 600 se encuentra a personas a nivel
nacional que pueden contar con este
beneficio por todo caso desde razones de
salud mayores de 50 años o con el 75% de
una discapacidad al no poder acercarse a
los centros de votación que ya
realizaron también su jornada electoral
también informarte que se está llevando
a cabo este proceso de votación con
estrictas medidas de bioseguridad el 911
es el encargado a nivel nacional de
monitorear que no se produzcan
concentraciones y este proceso deberá
realizarse luego cuando los electores
deben cumplir
con un proceso un protocolo de
bioseguridad no pueden coincidir tanto
ingresos y salidas en los recintos
electorales deben mantener el uso de las
mascarillas y geles
deben de igual forma y realizar el
proceso de votación dependiendo al
número terminal de la cédula un gran
número de cámaras a nivel nacional
estarán monitoreando que no se produzcan
aglomeraciones en todo el país y de
igual forma finalmente anunciarte que el
ejecutivo nacional ha decretado vía
decreto ejecutivo la creación de un
comité de transición para el próximo
gobierno